[Music]
it's been a minute been way too long I'm
glad you're here now first time in her
studio and you've been a busy girl yes I
have been very busy we just launched my
first baking line and I'm going on to
her I feel like it's always been a dream
of yours to make this collection - how's
it yes definitely I've always wanted to
make a baking line because I love baking
it's so creative and I've been
developing these things for over a year
and a half and I want to make a lot of
items that were really good for beginner
bakers and also intermediate bakers so
it ranges with both where the
inspiration comes from basically I
thought to myself what are products that
don't exist that I want to exist and
what are products that already exist but
I want to make them better - I am
someone who spends a lot of time in the
kitchen a lot of time baking so I kind
of have some pet peeves about some of my
everyday you know bowls and measuring
cups so I made some things that were a
little bit more functional for me and
fun like for example the treat mold that
looks like it has little poo cavities I
thought this is so neat it doesn't exist
anywhere I'm in a 3d molded pool there's
so much food I know isn't it crazy to
think like this all that came from a
passion for baking obviously and stuff
like that and now it's this brand I mean
you're a bet New York Times best seller
you're coming up is that crazy to hear
yeah cuz I just like making things I'm
just a creative person who loves
creating things I love making videos I
love making food I'm working on the
second one
maybe please I'd like to read this poem
so we're recipes you're cooking up in
your head no pun intended you need to be
put in a book for beginners like me I am
I took a lot of feedback from the first
cookbook and I've been working on
something some things are cooking you're
about to go embark on a nationwide tour
yeah with your fellow fans and in
support of this big plan I mean what do
you most looking forward to because
you're going city to city my favorite
thing about touring is getting to meet
my community because most of the year
you know I'm cooped up in my house
I'm baking all day and
and I just like to get out of the house
and there's something so special I've
talked about this before but meeting
fans and people face-to-face so we're
gonna decorate some cookies right yes I
brought a whole bunch of little cookies
now these ones are the final cookies
what they look like this is a shortbread
recipe thank you so this is a little
nerdy nummies logo and this little
device is from the baking line it's a
cookie stamp if you've never used a
cookie stamp before the reason I like
them for beginner bakers is because you
just roll out the dough you just stamp
them Boop that easy you can feel it oh
my god really easy it leaves impressions
in the dough and then after you bake
them you can use little icing and just
fill them in kind of like an edible
coloring book I thought that would be
really fun yeah let's do it here here's
a cookie
no I looked away the glass is broke
that's a wingtip
[Music]
but a trap there you go
boom yours is real cute let's show yours
real quick it's mine mine labuda tooth
to face but I don't what it's beautiful
you know what she's got attitude that's
what it is and it's still delicious we
can at least take a bite we can do a
Cheers
richer's tight ears
[Music]
you